biographie que la visitation la dernière
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que l'économie
n'oubliez pas de consulter le syllabus
de géographie qui vous donne toute la
matière de cet exposé pour répondre à la
question qu'est ce que l'économie on va
se poser une autre question à quoi sert
à l'économie l'économie c'est quelque
chose de très important puisque c'est ce
qui nous permet de répondre à nos
besoins que sont nos besoins dans le
syllabus est ici vous avez la pyramide
de maslow du nom de son auteur qui nous
montre les différents besoins base de la
pyramide j'ai les besoins les plus
importants ce qu'on va appeler les
besoins physiologiques
c'est à dire répondre à ma faim répondre
à ma soif répondre ma sexualité à ma
respiration à mon sommeil tout ça c'est
très important je dois à éliminer ses
besoins là pour vivre ce sont les
besoins essentiels
ensuite j'ai des besoins de sécurité
être dans un environnement stable
prévisible sans anxiété son cri sans
violence ensuite j'ai un besoin
d'appartenance être aimé par mes proches
avoir des amis et ensuite j'ai d'autres
besoins comme le besoin d steam ou
d'accomplissement de soi
vous voyez que d'abord il faut répondre
à des besoins essentiels à mes besoins
physiologiques
avant de penser à mes besoins de
sécurité et bien l'économie permet de
répondre à tous ces besoins qu'il soit à
la base ou en haut de la pyramide
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut répondre à
ses besoins et pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut réfléchir à ça mais parce que les
ressources sont limitées
il ya un concept de rareté des choses
sont rares il n'y a pas de la nourriture
pour tout le monde
il n'y a pas des habitats pour tout le
monde
il n'y a pas possibilité à tout le monde
de se déplacer en automobile
des choses comme ça donc l'économie
permet de répondre à ces questions là
alors si vous me dites oui mais
finalement nous maintenant on a tous ya
plus de rareté c'est un petit peu faux
parce qu'à l'échelle du monde ici je
vous ai mis un petit petite
représentation graphique où chaque petit
bonhomme représente 100 millions
d'individus et vous voyez qu'à l'échelle
mondiale
ben vous avez déjà 2,5 milliards de
personnes qui n'ont pas ou
occasionnellement accès
l'électricité et j'ai 2 8 milliards de
personnes qui vivent dans des régions où
il y a des problèmes d'eau
on n'a pas de l'eau assez pour tout le
monde vous voyez que ce sont quand même
des besoins physiologiques de base qui
sont même pas encore remplies pour quasi
un tiers de la population mondiale
alors maintenant je peux répondre qu'est
ce que l'économie finalement bien ce
sont toutes les activités qui vont
permettre de répondre à ses besoins en
fonction de la rareté des ressources
c'est à dire qu'il ya trois activités
essentielles en économie le fait de
produire de produire quelque chose de
répartir ce quelque chose et ensuite que
les personnes consomment ce quelque
chose évidemment si quelqu'un produit
des chaussures et qu'elle reste dans
l'usiné qu'elle ne sont pas répartis
elles ne sont pas distribués
ça ne sert à rien et puis si elle se
trouve dans les magasins avec personne
n'a suffisamment d'argent que pour les
consommer quelque part ça ne sert à rien
non plus donc ce sont ces trois
activités là qui sont au coeur de
l'économie alors de le dire mais ce
quelque chose c'est quoi mais ce sont
des biens et des services
l'économie vise donc à produire répartir
à consommer des biens et des services
dans les bien j'ai des biens de
consommation ce sont les biens que tout
le monde consomme 1 c'est pas tout ce
qui est toute la nourriture les boissons
les vêtements votre gsm mais à côté de
ça il y avait bien une production et là
c'est plutôt les entreprises qui vont
utiliser ces biens de production puisque
les biens de production ce sont les
biens qui permettent de produire
d'autres biens par exemple les outils ou
les machines ou un tracteur
voilà des ensembles de biens de
production qui ne me permettent de
produire des biens de consommation
j'ai aussi des services qui sont
produits qui sont répartis et consommer
les services et une prestation
c'est quelque chose que quelque chose de
quelqu'un fait qu'un prestataire fait
parce qu'il a des compétences
particulières parce qu'il a du matériel
particulier parce qu'il a une technique
particulière
j'ai des services marchands par exemple
notre coiffeur il ya un service marchand
votre banque
c'est un service marchand à côté de ça
j'ai des services non marchands
ce sont des services qui ne sont pas
voués à faire un bénéfice par exemple
les hôpitaux des écoles notaires se sont
toute une série de services non
marchands
certains de ses services non marchands
sont des services publics
c'est quoi un service public de c'est un
service qui va sérieux qui va profiter à
tout le monde
c'est par exemple l'éducation la santé
les transports la justice les poches
le courrier tout ça en fait ce sont des
missions qui sont remplies par l'état ou
par des régions des collectivités ce
qu'on appelle des collectivités en fait
c'est une association d'individus et ses
différentes activités vont être financés
par les impôts et les taxes on lui dans
une société où les impôts et les taxes
sont un peu mal vu mais imaginez une
société où il n'ya pas de chemin de fer
où il n'y a pas de centre hospitalier où
il n'y a pas de bureau de poste d'école
de palais de justice pour rendre la
justice pas de parc à conteneurs alors
ici géant reprend la couverture d'un la
couverture d'un livre français qui vous
montre un petit peu tous les services
publics mais ce sont deux services
auxquels on est confrontés tous les
jours comme un don qui sont très
importants alors certains de ces
services peuvent être un instrument
rempli par le privé un moment la poste
ça va être mis en concurrence par des
entreprises privées donc c'est plus
l'état qui gère la poste sont
différentes entreprises
le mot économie ça peut avoir plusieurs
sens alors attention de ne pas se
tromper
il ya d'abord l'économie comme
discipline l'économie comme discipline
c'est ce que c'est ce dont j ai parlé
c'est ce qui permet d'étudier tout le
fonctionnement de la répartition la
repro de la production de la
consommation des biens des services
maintenant toutes ces activités là si je
m'intéresse à toutes ces activités là
pour un pays c'est l'économie du pays en
fait dans le discours de tous les jours
quand vous parlez chez vous et vos
parents parlent parfois peut-être de
faire des économies
ça n'a rien à voir ça c'est pas renié
c'est un élément différent de ceux dont
je parlais